my name is Consuelo Dutch Kate I'm the
curator of medieval renaissance
manuscripts here at Columbia and part of
my job is to introduce my kinds of
materials to the Columbia graduate
students and undergraduates and when I
am showing them a book or manuscript
that has been rebound or repaired I'm
very aware of telling the students this
comes from conservation it's a very rare
and wonderful thing to have conservation
that conservation department right here
that works with rare books and rare
materials the conservation people have
knowledge about the physical properties
of objects about the chemistry so that
they can devise the correct kinds of
treatments for the objects they're aware
of art in that they devise treatments
that will be aesthetically pleasing and
at the same time and perhaps most
importantly they're aware of history
they try very hard to understand how an
object was originally used and how we
use it today how it the kind of life
it's led and to blend this into a good
and a solid and a real repair treatment
this is a document of Queen Elizabeth
the first she signed it in 1580 this
document has on it the kind of seal
that's typical and normal for a document
that comes from the English monarchs
it's a double-sided seal it has on this
side the monarch and throne and on the
other side the monarch on horseback
conservation is carefully given as a
means here to lift this and turn it over
so that we can actually see the other
side of the seal while at the same time
keeping it stored and keeping it
perfectly protected the document came to
us probably in the exact same way it had
lived it had survived for centuries it
was folded up into a rectangle that
perhaps was this size you can somewhat
see the marks on the parchment that are
still there this is again the kind of
thing where by conservation helps us to
help our readers they flatten the
document but it's not flat the way a
poster would be flat they didn't turn it
into a postcard we can still see these
fold marks the document still shows to
us the life that it's had in between the
day when Queen Elizabeth signed it in
and when we're looking at it here today
this wonderful little book is 13th
century English it has the statutes the
promulgation from the kings of England
starting with a copy of Magna Carta and
running up through the last statute is
of Edward the second who died in 1327
what I can show the students with this
book is a perfect synchronization of
form and function everything works
together in this book the text it's the
text that is used by the local sheriff
in administering local justice it has
the abstractions of the laws and then he
uses common law to actually decide the
particular legal action he's going to
take and it's a perfect little book to
fit in your hand just like that what
conservation did for this book is they
turned it back into a book again until
they did this put the current binding on
it it was completely in tatters
completely shreds leaf by leaf the
process of rebinding was a very long one
for example here's one of the two models
that they made in preparation but this
one didn't open well enough and so they
did yet another one to make sure that
they got the kind of book that would
open properly they produced a binding
that doesn't pretend to be medieval it's
an honest functional viable decent
binding without any pretense without
fakeness and yet it gives the sense of
what the book is this particular book
which was produced in the first half of
the 15th century in England is
encyclopedia it's a huge book as you can
see it probably took 190 kaif scans to
produce all of this parchment on this
book huge book very expensive it weighs
43 pounds even now it takes two of us to
pick it up what the book has in it are
smudges they occur sporadically on this
leaf there are three of them right in
here and another one right in there the
suggestion had been made that they were
thumb prints from the printer wink and
award who was working on the manuscript
this would be very exciting news to
actually have the thumb prints of
somebody as important as one of
England's very first printers wink and
award last year Arita walked in our
front door and said
I've come to see the thumb prints we got
the book out and we all looked at it and
we can't tell if these a thumb prints or
not but conservation of course can and
not just because they have microscopes
and can look at things in more detail
more precisely than we can because the
people in conservation know how ink
reacts they know how parchment behaves
they know how the blood of a slain
animal can pool in the skin and because
of all of this the people in
conservation resolve the difficulty no
they said that's a defect in parchment
making that's not winging into words
thumb print so maybe we're a little bit
disappointed but what we have now is the
truth and we can trust it what
conservation has done for us the
curators what conservation has done for
us the viewing public is to put our
materials into a physical context to
make us understand the kinds of
materials that we're dealing with that
otherwise we ourselves can't understand